hey everyone I'm here with Jake and he
got to see Immortals of AVM the upcoming
uh first person Magic game yeah that EA
is putting out uh Jake I'm gonna be
honest this game didn't really seem like
it was for me it wasn't on my radar and
you said it wasn't on your radar either
but now that you've had a chance to play
it you seem like you're actually a
little bit excited for it yeah I'm I'm
excited somewhat impressed uh I think I
didn't really know what to expect I I
just seemed kind of like a generic uh
first person Magic based game sure but
honestly it feels like Call of Duty but
you cast spells and stuff
[Music]
you've got like your pistol spell and
you've got your shotgun spell and you've
got your machine gun spell and you press
y to switch through them and you can
upgrade them and it feels like a very
linear scripted Call of Duty campaign
but in a I guess unique setting or
wrapper I don't know how long this game
is going to be I don't know much about
it other than what I played and it seems
fun like I was having a good time
shooting people with all my spells
reloading my Magic Hands by like doing
like things like this yeah the Magic
Hands is definitely like feels like the
the thing that it has like I I that's
the thing that I I didn't think ghost of
our Tokyo was a good game unfortunately
but I did love the idea of just like
shooting spells with your hands like
you're doing your little hand Jutsu and
so like seeing this game also
incorporate that is uh definitely seems
like that's the hook
um and it it's like hard to say like how
much is there based on what I played
like you've got three weapons for for
spells I guess that you switch between I
don't know if you get more yeah I don't
know like you can upgrade them it seems
but I don't know how in depth that goes
but yeah I mean My Demo started out as
like a bad guys are attacking yep it
felt very very scripted and very uh
action heavy and I walked down started
blasting enemies fought a dragon at the
end that almost kind of felt bullet
helly
so it seems interesting yeah I I did get
to watch some of the cut scenes the
story uh did not interest me at all
um it seemed very
I don't know straightforward the main
character was just seemed like generic
man okay
uh so so I don't know I mean it's hard
to say I just saw one cut scene maybe
with proper setup and an understanding
of that world I might be more invested
but I think being thrown in at that part
and I was like I don't really care about
these characters okay um one thing that
was kind of funny though is that the
main character's name is Jack and he'd
say regularly and there was uh subtitles
and it would just say Jackson
oh
uh which I thought was kind of funny
okay let's point that out but but yeah
I'm I'm somewhat optimistic I'm looking
forward to it it seemed a little buggy
but uh it comes out like July 20th so
hopefully they can work that stuff out
and I think it'll be a solid I think it
could be a solid uh like single player
experience sure yeah yeah I mean um
we'll have to see when it fully comes
out obviously final judgment but I can
definitely see this as like a maybe not
at least for me not maybe quite when it
comes out but oh it's not it's you know
it's on sale or Here Comes The Game Pass
or something could be cool um actually
wait it will because oh because it's the
originals yeah yeah oh well actually
that's the perfect excuse then wow all
right cool uh anything else you want to
save out the game or not really pretty
straightforward yeah all right well
that's just a very straightforward uh
impressions of uh Mortals of idiom uh
for more things from Summer Games Fest
summer game Fest singular game singular
game stay tuned to GameSpot
[Music]